point of today's presentation is to give
everyone some information about the
training modules being offered through
lsu's gene lab this semester
their focus is always going to be on
data science and bioinformatics it's
offered primarily through the omics
logic portal
which is offered by pine biotech as well
as their backing on from the tober
institution so just to give you a brief
overview there are three different
training models that are going to be
offered this uh this semester each
semester there'll be different uh
modules being offered uh but there's
just three for now
the big push for these training modules
is that they're completely asynchronous
so you guys can take them at whatever
rate is best for you
so if you take longer to learn some
subjects you can take your time to go
through those subjects or if you're
quicker and others you can move faster
but you're not going to be doing this
entirely alone like these programs are
intended to teach you how to do things
properly right so there are going to
also be mentor-led lectures which are
also asynchronous so if your schedule
doesn't line up with the lecture times
or you aren't available one day over
another you can always watch the
lectures at a later date because they'll
be entirely
recorded there's also going to be a
variety of tools that are available to
help you through the programs
so one of them is going to be the online
chat assistance so you guys can always
ask questions through a variety of tools
that you'll discuss in each
individual program's orientation
so you'll always have experts available
to you if you get stuck or if you have a
more advanced question that you don't
know is actually if it's covered in the
training module or not there are experts
available at all times
if you're with lsu um or coming through
lvrn and you have an indirect question
or you don't know who to ask the
question to you'll probably be directing
that question to me my name is lane
yetzi
some of you may know me through the pbs
department at lsu school of vet med
but if you need to reach me at any time
we will have the information in the chat
my email is lyutzy1
at lsu.edu and i'll put that in the chat
right now for you
so if you have any indirect questions
that aren't answered today or if you're
you don't want to you don't think of
them at this moment you can always reach
out to me at that email address
that being said
once you complete any aspect of this
program or the entirety of the program
you'll receive a certificate of
completion
and this is going to be different i'm
going to show you some of this
information later on but this is going
to be a unique certificate to whatever
training module that you take
and it'll be signed and backed by an
individual of your institution so if
you're with lsu you're going to have
that certificate signed by dr gus
kasulis
and if you're with lbrn
the person is tentative but it is likely
to be chris taylor if you're familiar
with him
so
how are you going to take these training
models how are they going to be
delivered to you there are three primary
platforms that we're going to be
discussing
throughout this
lecture here the biggest one you're
going to interact with is the omics
logic portal this is essentially a
website that gives you access to all of
the lessons all of the program
information and all of the assignments
that you'll utilize throughout this
training module i'll show you a bit more
in detail later on uh how this portal
works and what it looks like but this is
the primary one you'll be interacting
with
if you're taking one of the more
advanced courses you'll also have
experience with their tbio platform
essentially what this is is it's a
flowchart system in which you can take
whatever data set you're going to be
utilizing
and it's going to work you step by step
through the process to analyze that data
and visualize that data for whatever
desired outcome you have
but this is going to be more for
individuals that are going through the
advanced projects
also another tool that will be available
to you that is really important for this
process is the python and r coding
playground
so for those of you that aren't as
familiar with the coding um like myself
as i was originally
whenever you code something you need to
create a proper coding environment for
the for the coding to actually run
properly now that can be kind of
difficult especially so i had no
experience uh prior to working with this
platform so i didn't know what i was
doing but luckily the omxlogic platform
provides a coding playground for you so
you don't have to do any of the setup
you can just practice the coding steps
yourself within their coding playground
so it makes a lot easier for you to
understand these processes
um and so there's two links that were
just put in the chat that's some more
information to the omixlogic
portal as well as the tbio platform if
you're curious
so there's three different difficulty
levels that i'm going to be discussing
with these training modules beginner
intermediate and advanced so to give you
an idea of where you may fall in those
three categories i'm going to describe a
little bit about what we consider a
beginner an intermediate and an advanced
level of expertise
so a beginner to us is someone who has
minimal background but it's biological
or data science you have maybe heard of
bioinformatics or you're familiar with
the concept of it and you're curious to
learn more about it how it's used in the
industrial research or clinical worlds
then you'd be considered more of a
beginner
if you're an intermediate level that
would mean you'd have some kind of
understanding of biological and data
science concepts maybe you have a little
bit of background in either one you've
had a little bit of statistical
experience maybe you've taken a
statistics course or you are familiar
with a little bit of the concepts and
you have maybe some coding experience
an advanced individual is someone who
has full understanding of the verbiage
used in biological and computational uh
fields so you understand whatever you're
reading you're not really hung up on a
lot of the words right
you have some statistical experience
again maybe you've taken a course or two
you've applied some stats to your own
projects
and then you have some coding experience
with our python so if you have
statistical experience most likely you
have
heard of or worked with r to some degree
and you also understand
next generation sequencing to some
extent if you have a biological
background which i'm sure many of you do
you've probably learned how next
generation sequencing works or at least
at the very minimal heard about the
different types of next-generation
sequencing that are growing in the
biotechnical field
so let's talk about each individual
training module that's being offered
this semester and what uh
what each module brings to the table
right
so
the first module i'll be discussing is
the beginner level getting started with
bioinformatics you'll also hear this
referred to as introduction to big data
bioinformatics or introduction to
bioinformatics but it's the same uh
thing across the board this is like i
said a beginner level training module
with a rough time equivalent uh time
commitment equivalent to about a one
credit course if we're thinking about an
equivalent to the difficulty level
there's probably more of a 100 or 1000
level depending on what institution
you're from
so it's very introductory it's just to
give you an overview of the key topics
and the applications
of bioinformatics that's from everything
from the basics of the biology that you
would need to understand this
information as well as applications of
big data and the modern world right
so if you don't have any background or
you only know a little bit and you don't
you just kind of want to dip your toe in
this might be the training module you're
interested in
now our intermediate training module
that's being offered this semester is
data science for biomedical data this is
more equivalent to a true credit hour
course and is closer to maybe a 200 or
300 level in the academic world
the purpose of this training module is
to teach you methods for how to wrangle
data analyze visualize all of your data
as well as a little bit about how
machine learning is applied to
bioinformatic data
so all of these concepts that you'll be
discussing and practicing are actually
using the analysis of omics in the real
world so it's to kind of give you
some of the tools you would need to
understand and even perform some of the
uh
the data analysis that's used in mx
studies
the third training module that's being
offered in the advanced field is the
bulk and single cell transcriptomics
training module like i said this is
advanced so this is someone who already
knows that they want to learn
specifically about transcriptomics
but maybe you want to learn more about
it or how to perform the steps of
analysis yourself
so that's the purpose of this training
module is to help you learn some of the
methods as well as visualization
techniques that are used to analyze both
bulk and single cell rna-seq so if
you're thinking about a way to integrate
data analysis specifically rna-seq data
analysis into your own work this would
be a great training module for you
so let's get into a little more
nitty-gritty of each individual training
module as to what are the subjects
covered etcetera etcetera right
so first things first
each training module is going to have
their own individual orientation that
will give you real in-depth uh
information about which tools you'll
need to access you know your expert help
when lectures are going to be available
and things like that
however even though the orientation for
getting started with bioinformatics is
going to be on october 6th because this
is asynchronous you'll have full access
to the omics logic portal on october 4th
so if you want to get a head start and
take some of the uh courses or some of
the lessons that are available to you in
this training module you'll be able to
do so at your own rate
so what exactly is getting started with
bioinformatics and what will it cover so
this is basically an introduction to
everything bioinformatics data science
is to give you a strong foundation and
the understanding of how to apply this
information to your own work
or sorry how to apply this information
in the world or in the real world um and
so it's going to cover a variety of
concepts to give you an idea of what
exactly is out there in the
bioinformatics world
so first we're going to start with
concepts you'll also get introductions
to some of the more subspecialties in
the omics fields such as genomics or
transcriptomics you'll learn about
differential gene expression machine
learning
and how those are applied in the
bioinformatics world to help
better our understanding of the data
we're analyzing
now you're going to understand that
you're going to learn how this
information is applied not just in the
research world also in the clinical
world in the biotechnical world how can
these be applied to different
fields throughout
throughout uh specifically uh the united
states as well as uh
academic institutions and industry
around the world right
you're also gonna see hands on how this
is done through a variety of case study
based projects so you're not just gonna
talk about conceptually how these things
are applied you're going to study
exactly how they have been applied
to different specialties around the
world right
so if you're curious and you want to get
more information you can go to the link
down below if it's a little bit a longer
link but if you have access to the
informational pamphlets the link is
available there as well
and they'll probably put it in a chat
here so you can just just click on the
link directly
so
these
training modules are built off of
asynchronous courses so this particular
training module getting started with
bioinformatics was built primarily off
of or inspired by these two training
asynchronous training courses
introduction to bioinformatics and bytes
and molecules
so there's a big difference here though
between the asynchronous courses and
these training modules so you if you go
to the omics logic portal at
learn.mxlogic.com you can have access to
a variety of the lessons free to
everyone right now you don't have to
sign up for anything and you can give
you an idea of what's available
to
individuals through this program right
so the difference though is when you're
taking these these individual
asynchronous courses
you're not getting a strong
understanding as to how everything is
interconnected you're learning the
syntax and you're understanding
everything that's being displayed to you
and you know instructed to you but the
purpose of these training models is to
really tie everything together to show
you how all of this information can be
synchronously combined
to your own work to future work to
different fields and how everything is
interconnected and can be utilized
together to progress uh either your own
research or research you're familiar
with right
so
that's the purpose of these training
modules there are they are inspired by
these asynchronous courses but the
purpose is to really show you how
everything is interconnected and
intermingle it with your own work and
the different tools available to you
they're broken into different lectures
that will help you
work your way through this training
module and again like i mentioned these
are asynchronous so if you can't make
these particular dates which these are
tentative dates uh they're open to uh
changing if people have issues with
schedules and stuff
if you don't aren't able to meet these
dates they're always going to be
available recorded to you
at upon this date after they've been um
delivered right
so you can reach out and you can watch
them at any time that's convenient to
you you can complete things earlier or
later at your earliest convenience right
each lecture will focus on particular
subspecialties uh and so you can see
some of them here i'm not going to go
through each one and each one of these
own lecture focuses will have different
subjects within them that you can see it
fully at the link uh provided in the
chat that will give you through the
entire syllabus you know what subject is
in each lecture what are the some of the
focuses of that particular subject um
you can see all that on the the link in
the chat right now
so like i just mentioned and kind of
discussed the purpose of introduction to
bioinformatics
is
really to provide you with a variety of
skills that you will need to understand
the bioinformatics world and understand
how it's applied in the real world so
you're going to learn a variety of
different things you're going to learn
python and r coding you're going to
learn a little bit about stats you're
going to learn about machine learning
and ai guided analysis specifically in
the context of next generation
sequencing right because that's what
you're usually more interested in and
how you can apply it to your own direct
work
and at the end of it all you're going to
get a certification supported from
whatever institution you're from whether
that's lsu or lbrn
so if this is particularly interesting
to you or you just want to kind of dip
your toe in this might be a great
training model for you
so moving on
the next training model that we're going
to discuss is the data science for
biomedical data the orientation to this
particular training module is october
7th again at 12 pm central time
and again your access is fully available
from the 4th you're going to see that
across the board october 4th you can
access all of the training models that
you sign up for
so what is the purpose of this
particular training module
the idea here is to show you how big
data is enter as mixed with biology how
can it be applied directly to biological
studies and how is it being used already
right
as we
you know further our knowledge about
biotechnical research you're gonna
you've already noticed throughout your
research papers that more and more
individuals are integrating things uh
like data science into their own studies
it's a great way to
further our understanding of our samples
to really see how massive changes are
occurring in different cell states and
however whatever your studies
particularly apply to i'm sure you've
noticed a growing increase uh focus on
data science integration
so this is what this course this
training module is trying to
uh show you right
you're gonna learn a lot of different
things you're not going through this
alone you know these as a biologist you
don't always have a lot of
exposure to data science uh usually it's
entirely on the the biology side of
things right so there's a variety of
tools that are going to be available to
help you through this process there's
hands-on exercise handling exercises
tutorials there's coding challenges
which if you're not familiar with coding
you know it'll help work you through the
steps it'll teach you the functions and
things you need to create to run the
processes you're trying to do
as well as you're going to see
real research examples we're all
familiar with images like this we've all
seen studies in papers like this right
so we're you're finally going to
understand and get to learn how people
are taking some of their data and
they're creating visualizations like
this how they're getting to these these
uh research papers
that's what the point of this particular
training module is is to learn how to
analyze that bioinformatic data
all the way from wrangling your data
through visualizing your data
so there's a variety of concepts you're
going to learn here this is just a few
of them this isn't all of them
but to give you an idea you're going to
learn about statistical concepts machine
learning and deep learning you're going
to learn some python and r coding
in general coding practices associated
with bioinformatics as well as data
sharing
and you're going to learn these both
conceptually and how they're applied
practically to the real world for both
research and clinical applications
and you're going to get to do it
yourself so this isn't just learning
about this you're going to practice
yourself with coding challenges and
different assignments along the way
these are training modules they're not
just
uh dumps of information to read you know
for you to read on your own you'll have
ways to apply this information to
practice this information yourself
and if you're more curious you can go to
the link that was provided in the chat
for this particular program
just like the last one here is the the
syllabus uh at least the lecture focuses
of the syllabus and some of the the
individual asynchronous courses that
were uh used in the inspiration of this
particular training module
you can see some of the stuff you're
going to learn uh throughout the course
in more depth here you know unsupervised
learning specifically clustering
supervised learning classification
if you're if this is interesting to you
or you can see how well you could apply
biomedical
data analysis to your own work
this might be the training module for
you this is the intermediate training
module and like i mentioned before it is
i've heard orientation for this training
model is october 7th
so our advanced training module being
offered this semester is the bulk and
single cell transcription mix training
module the orientation for this one is
october 8th so you can if you've noticed
the trend i'm sure
uh introduction is on the sixth
uh biomedical data is on the seventh and
then transfector is on the eighth again
all access is available october 4th so
if you want to get a head start you're
more than welcome to
so what's the point of this particular
training module it's to provide you with
a variety of tools on how
transcriptomics is directly applied to
your own research or research that you
wish to get into in the future you're
going to learn a variety of methods to
help you do this
uh different for analysis methods
statistical analysis as well as uh
clustering information
data mining classification of data
and so eventually you'll be able to
visualize uh whatever data you're
working with in a variety of ways
so this is for individuals that really
know that they want to integrate
transphobics into their own work and uh
unfortunately for you if you have your
own data already and you're just curious
as to how to analyze it and apply it
that is uh you're able to actually do
that in this training module
you're going to learn about how to uh
perform transcriptomic related data
analysis and visualize that data but
you're also going to have a project
later on that'll take you from start to
finish of a whole transcriptomic project
so if you have your own data you can
actually use that there uh and do the
project with your own data so you're
progressing your own research
potentially
while learning about how to do these uh
transfer thermic data analysis right
you're going to learn a lot about a lot
of different things in this module uh
and this is why it's considered more of
an advanced module you'll understand
more in-depth concepts with machine
learning for specifically for
expression-based data
exploratory data analysis
here you'll learn about how to analyze
and process gene expression data
specifically that associated with
next-generation sequencing
you'll learn how to data mine as well as
you're going to learn how to apply this
through the biological interpretations
that you may have heard so i know i'm
sure many of you are familiar with
pathway analysis or have seen
papers discussing pathway analysis
you're going to learn how to do that
here with your data
so this particular
training module is for individuals that
have some background and all of the
information discussed and want to really
further that and not integrate it into
their own transcriptomic studies right
that's just that can also be bulk and
single cell so if you have one
particular one in mind you'll learn
about both in this training market
so here's the syllabus and again some of
the asynchronous courses that have
inspired this training module i'm not
going to go through in full detail but
again the orientation is on october 8th
you can see some of the subjects
discussed in this particular trade
module
to give you an idea of all of the things
that are going to be there to help you
through this process
this slide gives you a lot of
information as to how
there this is really designed to help
you succeed it's not just leaving you
high and dry to learn the information on
your own there's a variety of courses
and tutorials available to you as i
mentioned there are
multiple mentors that will be available
to help you through the process right
you're going to be guiding yourself
but there's plenty of tools that are
there to make sure that you succeed
all the methods that are going to be
discussed will be explained to you so
you can fully understand why you're
doing what you're doing
and you can start to understand
different ways to help improve the
analysis that you're doing with
multi-omics ai guided analysis you start
to understand gene expression data
better
as well as data science you'll do some
of the coding like i mentioned
and then you'll see how this is directly
applied to your own fields of expertise
right your own biomedical next
generation sequencing research could be
furthered from this training module as
well as that project that i mentioned
has the potential to eventually be uh
you could present it as a proposal or
poster or presentation at
a
conference in the future
so speaking of that particular uh
potential
there are some available resources too
that you may not be aware of
so
if you guys are from lsu or lbrn there
is the lsu gene lab available to you
gene lab
provides a variety of consulting and
experimental services that could be
beneficial to your research
so gene lab
some of the services this is just some
if you're curious you can go to their
website to learn more but they offer a
variety of sequencing and next
generation sequencing
services pcr services gel imaging
multiplex protein analysis and as well
as automated cell counting services at
genelab
if you're with lbrn
there's the lbrn bioinformatics
biostatistics and computational biology
core
which is designed to provide a
consulting mentorship and training
through their bioinformatics liaisons
this is primarily focused towards pis
but uh so you can reach out to them
directly
to learn more about how to be further
trained in these fields
as i mentioned about that project
uh there or the project that you could
present there is the annual lbrn
conference on computational biology and
bioinformatics this is usually in the
spring last year it was around april
so you have the potential to present
your projects that you're working on at
this conference or a similar conference
of your choice
if you choose to do so there are always
ways to continue furthering your
education
now if you're a faculty member here
today and you're curious about these
programs there are a variety of other
training modules offered through pine
biotech
that if you are curious about how to
offer programs like this to your own
institution or to your own students
you can reach out to elia brodsky he is
in the call today he's the ceo of pine
biotech his email is ilya pine.bio so if
you email him uh you can get a variety
information about some of the programs
and training models that have been
offered at a variety of institutions
across the country as well as throughout
louisiana
so if that's something that may interest
you definitely reach out to ilya
so
if anyone is interested i'm going to
reiterate one more time that all access
begins october 4th what i haven't
mentioned is that all access will end
december 31st so
if you have a busy schedule where you
really have to structure your schedule
or you're worried about well these
courses may overlap with some of my own
courses at my academic institution
that's fine you have plenty of time to
complete all of the information as long
as you keep up with it right it is it
has to be treated like a normal one of
your courses but you'll have plenty of
time to complete assignments and balance
your schedule accordingly
this shouldn't be overwhelming to you no
one wants it to be overwhelming to you
so the best thing that's why the trading
models will
last until december 31st so if you need
additional time you can schedule
accordingly
so i'm gonna the next thing i'm gonna do
is i'm gonna show everyone how to
register on both the learn omics logic
portal as well as
how to register for these courses
um
so we'll now open up the questions
before i do that and i see one question
in the chat can you enroll in more than
one of these courses
you can at the moment uh but it has to
be approved so the issue is we don't
want someone with
uh
a background that say you say you want
to take intro and you want to take
transfer comments right so there's a
different different uh different
difficulty levels we don't want one
individual to go into transcriptomics
and not have the background they need to
excel right
so it is possible but it has to be
approved from
the organization that you're associated
with
is it possible to only audit the courses
yeah no i think
after
this you're going to be showing the
portal and on that portal
in each course there are some free
lessons
so if you just register
take a look at some of those examples
and then decide if that's something that
you want to do and proceed with the full
registration
okay so if you guys go to
learn.mclogics.com which it has been
mentioned in the chat
um
there it is again
so if you guys go here
you'll see
clearly in the center of the page
register for free so if you want to
register like i said there are some
training uh lessons
available for free you don't have to
register for anything in terms of these
programs they're available to everyone
so if you want to get an idea of how the
portal is structured
that's a great way to do so so you're
going to click here for register for
free
and so if you don't already have an
account you're going to click right here
to create an account
all i have to do is put your information
in the name email make a password right
or you can also sign up with a variety
of other methods google facebook apple
etc
okay and i'll take you here so the
biggest thing that you're going to
remember to do is go to your profile
that's the easiest way to access
everything so once you get to your
profile this is what it'll look like you
might not have a profile picture but
or a description but feel free to put
that information in you can also link
your socials if you choose to do so
which indeed
um
and you'll notice right away you'll have
a subscription down here and a level so
as you complete different lessons and go
through the program this level will
increase so you get points for
completing things you can see here i got
500 for for completing starting with
bioinformatics and python
and your goal is eventually get to 10
000.
the reason the goal is to get to ten
thousand is once you get to ten thousand
you'll unlock projects
uh which if you follow the program
appropriately uh you'll get ten thousand
before you're required to start your
project
now when you first make your account
you'll notice your subscription is
probably different
and you won't have any badges down here
but once you register for a training
module your the training module you
register for will come up down here as a
badge so you can see here's the
different training models that we
discussed today right
so the point of this is
once you start a course or a project or
a program
you can see all of them here at the top
you go to courses
you'll see all the courses that you've
started working on
so as you can see i've completed course
one here python course one and as you
work through it you'll start to see that
this
value increases as you complete the
different lessons within the courses now
once you complete a course you'll still
get a certificate for completing that
course similar to the one that you'll
get at the end for completing the
program but the one you'll get at the
end when you complete your program is
specific to that program and to the
institution so you can use that as an
indication that you've been trained in
bioinformatics in that particular
subject
so
what do these certificates look like um
if this will if this loads i can give
you an idea of what it looks like okay
so this is kind of what your certificate
will look like except you know your name
will be here
um this is just for the lesson right so
as i mentioned it's going to be
different for once you complete your
program
but uh if you're once you complete the
program you'll probably see decals for
uh
lsu or lvrn depending on what
institution you're working with they'll
also be signed by a specific individual
so dr augusta solis will sign here with
your lsu or potentially someone from
ldrn as well as the date as to when you
finish the program right
so going back
if you want to find uh
out the programs you're in you can go to
the programs tag here or tab here and
this will show you what your progress is
in the program it will also give you
information about the program right so
if you sign up for biomed introduction
to bioinformatics
or data science or transformations like
we just discussed this will show up here
as well so if you want to find it you
may not see it down here you can go to
the programs tab
if you're starting new and you want to
find new courses you can go to this
course selection here
and search different introductory
courses at your leisure
if you get to the project so once you
get to 10 000 points in the project this
will unlock and it'll take you step by
step through how to make a project on
omixlogic from start to finish from
choosing your data set choosing your
hypothesis and working through the
different steps associated with the
project
so that being said the next thing i want
to show you how to do this is how to
register on omixlogic if you want to
register for the training modules
you're going to go
to uh ilabs
which is the
at my ilabsolutions.com
plus account log in
so if you don't have an ilab account
you're going to have to make an ilab
account
i'll wait if you want to do this with me
and you already have an ilab account
i'll go ahead and hold up for a second
but
uh for those individuals that don't i
will also put a document
in the chat that will take you step by
step how to do it so you'll have that
available to you
if you choose to register
so that document will help you go
through it uh step by step if you missed
a step today while i'm talking about it
and still want to register or if you
haven't made your i haven't made a
decision yet and you just want to sit on
them for a little bit
just download that document and you'll
be able to register at any time
so actually uh i'm we're going to log in
with another individual's account
who has
fortunately given us
their access information to kind of show
you what it's going to look like
since i'm an admin one
uh
the account it looks a little different
for me
so once you sign in here's the first
thing you're going to notice
is this screen you're going to log in
you'll should see something like this
you might not see the service request
down here
but you'll see the home page
okay
what you're going to want to do
is you're going to go up here to this
drop down menu in the top left
when you click on that drop down menu
you're going to want to look for
core facilities okay
if you click on core facilities
it'll take you to the variety of core
facilities offered through lsu or the
lbrn network
the one you're going to want to look for
is the cder core facilities and services
the cei dr core facilities and services
primary contact is theo
you're going to click on that
okay
oops so i have to stop sharing this for
a second
because of some personal information
that
should not be shown
actually so let me show you first so
first you're going to want to click once
you get to this page you're going to
want to click on request services up
here in the view my requests okay
click on request services
and that'll take you to a new page
when you get to the request services
page
most of you should have this drop down
if not go ahead and click the drop down
box for project requests
and then you're going to want to look
for training modules
here are the three training modules that
we discussed today you can see you're
going to want to click on request
service
here on the right side once you've found
training modules select request service
like i mentioned i'm going to stop
sharing just for a second
because
i need to hide some information
okay but once you get there you'll have
a portion at the top will have your
identification information
like your lab your phone number your
email right
scroll down just a little bit until you
find training modules and it should have
a little
a little red star next to it
you'll see here that these are the three
training models that we discussed today
in the training module box type
whichever one of those training models
you want to take part in
if you want to take part in more than
one or a curious if you're able to type
that in there as well as as well and
i'll be in contact with you through ilab
once you've done that
and it's a little easier if you don't
want to type it you can just highlight
copy and paste
once you've done that
scroll down
a little bit farther until you see
payment information
once you've found payment information
there'll be a small box that says fund
number
this is not a required field but to help
us figure out which institution you're
associated with
type in this box whether you're with lsu
or whether you're with lbr
once you have done that
all you have to do is click here submit
request decor
and you're done
so once you do that your registration is
complete
you may get one additional email just
from ilab saying something about costs
don't worry about that
that's just for our purposes it informs
you that we are
processing your information
now if this uh if you're stuck on this
uh like i said download that document
you'll be able to go it takes you
through step by step
through all of the information we've
discussed and how to do it
so or if you have any additional
questions feel free to throw them in the
chat now
um or if you have another question you
think of later like i said you can
always reach out to me at l y u t z y
one at lsu.edu
so with that
i'll open up
uh oh yes so i also want to show you the
some of the landing pages so the links
that everyone linked here
in the
document as well
to kind of give you an idea of what the
landing pages will look like right
so
if you go to one of these landing pages
or one of the links provided in the box
you'll see this so this is your getting
started with bioinformatics landing page
this will give you more information
about that particular training module if
you're curious or want to re-read some
of the stuff that we discussed today
go to one of these links
and this is how this is how i present to
you so you'll have a brief description
of what this particular training module
is intended to show you
it'll tell you when the orientation
session is for that individual training
session as i mentioned it's the sixth
for the introduction course
seven for big data bioinformatics and
then eighth for the transcriptomics
training model
you'll have a short video uh available
to you that'll kind of give you a bit
more detail about what the goals of the
training module are and what's included
in it
as well as some of the key topics that
are going to be covered
and what is really important is if you
really want an in-depth overview of how
this training module is going to
function you can continue to scroll down
and you'll see the full program syllabus
for that particular training market
it'll cover all of the major topics as
well as some of the minor topics i
discussed for each particular lecture
that will be covered so example as i
mentioned you're going to get
introductions to genomics and
transcendence for the introductory
course
so here's some of the sub points that
are covered in the genomics lecture
targeted sequencing whole genome xm
sequencing whole genome sequencing etc
etc you'll also see uh
more information about each one of the
subject matters discussed because i only
went over a few of them in this
particular
election
now if you like i mentioned before if
you do need help or you run into any
issues or something
uh skips your memory as to what to do
you could always contact me at
elliott1lsu.edu
or you can join the orientation session
for that particular program uh which
will have links in the future
now if you're curious and you're in uh
and you want more information or you
want to show your interest go ahead and
go down to any of those pages and
register here listing your information
uh and these boxes to help us
uh figure out who you're associated with
and then we can reach out to you
for more information on how to register
if you're with an outside institution
if you're curious as to what some of the
asynchronous
courses that i discussed are like a full
list of them here are some of the lists
here as well as this is more close to
what the certificate will look like when
you complete your training module
so if you have any more uh questions or
information go ahead and shoot that in
the chat
and otherwise um unless ilya if you have
anything else you would like to add in
thank you for your time
thank you i know i will just add
a couple of points so the differences
between the programs
it sounds like several of the topics are
almost the same
but it's really the depth as to
you know each topic that is going to be
covered
and the specific focus so even though on
all the programs different types of
omics data different types of methods
and categories of methods are going to
be touched on
the depth of
those topics and the specific focus is
going to be very different
for example
in the introduction to bioinformatics
module most of the topics are going to
be a high level overview
in the
data science it's going to be primarily
downstream analysis data visualization
and
finding patterns using machine learning
in the transcriptomics it is going to be
much more focused on actual biological
discovery using those methods of
analysis including both
bulk and single cell rna-seq data and it
is really intended to kind of help you
work with an existing data set so we'll
focus
on different types of data that you can
either identify in the public domain
or if you have data of your own you can
use that as well
so just wanted to make sure that that is
clear